- Fear is the resistance to
what it is that you desire.
And in the absence of resistance,
you become a magnet for what you desire.
Your successes will come
when you commit to joy,
when you commit to happiness.
You could say all the right things,
but if you don't think it,
if you don't transform and
clean up your thinking,
then you're literally
polluting the planet.
- She's a motivational
speaker, life coach,
and spirit junkie.
She's a New York Times best selling author
of the Universe Has Your Back.
Her flagship course, A
Spirit Junkie Masterclass,
empowers people to live their best self.
She's Gabrielle Berstein
and here's my take
on her top 10 rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Don't wait.
Go.
Do it.
Act now.
And really accepting we need
you, we need you, we need you.
You are the 1%.
You're the percent that
says, "I'm going to wake up."
You are the light workers.
You are the ones that
have accepted this call
in this lifetime at this time.
You have decided to wake
up and chosen to say,
"Yes, I'm here to be of greater service
"than just to feed myself," right?
I'm here to feed the world.
I'm here to give love.
I'm here to be an
expression of that truth.
Don't hold that back.
Don't play small.
We can't.
We need you.
And so really, if you
are anyone in this room
who has been sitting on that book idea,
waiting a little bit longer
before you start that teacher training,
or doing 10 more teacher trainings
before you actually teach,
(laughter)
if that's you guys,
start and the pressure will be off.
I can't begin to tell you.
I could cry just saying this.
The day I taught Ego Eradicator,
I was two weeks into my teacher training
and I said, "F it, let's go!"
And I just went and I
felt so much pressure off.
I felt so much lift because I just knew.
I felt this technology must be shared.
I can't hold it.
I can't keep it for myself.
I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this.
I got to give this.
(laughter)
And sharing it, the pressure just lifted.
It was like (sighs).
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And I wasn't the perfect
teacher and I look back
and I was teaching Ego Eradicator wrong.
Everyone's arms were like this.
Everyone was breathing backwards.
It was a mess.
But I did it and I started.
And in those moments when
we just to go, just go,
the pressure's off and
then we clear the path
and we are guided to
the next right action.
And that is the most magnificent thing
we could do right now.
- What's the first step
to overcoming the fear
or transforming the fear?
- To witness it.
To be the nonjudgmental witness of it.
To look at it and say,
"Something's got to give," right?
So if you're unwilling to
look at your fear head on
and honor it and witness.
I always say if you don't
show up for what's up
it will keep showing up.
So looking and saying I
witnessed my resistance
and you see that fear as resistance.
Fear is the resistance to
what it is that you desire.
And in the absence of resistance,
you become a magnet for what you desire.
And when you let go of that fear
and you transcend that fear,
that's when you start to
become a super attractor.
That's when you start to let what is truly
of essence for you into your life.
What is truly of service
for you into your life.
What is true happiness into your life.
And so looking at the fear, witnessing it,
calling it by its name.
And even if you don't have the tools yet,
what happens is when you look
at the fear and you're like
oh, I see this fear,
I see this resistance,
I see how it's blocking my life
and I chose to see it differently.
That's when you listen
to an audio like this.
That's when a book like yours
will fall off the shelf.
- A catalyst will open up.
- Yeah.
Exactly, you open up your
consciousness, pretty much.
You crack open your
consciousness to find solutions
rather than find problems.
- Right.
- And so when you're
not looking at the fear,
you're just living in the fear
and you're believing in the problem.
But when you witness the fear
and you're willing to see it differently,
you start living in the solution.
As I commit to happiness fully,
exactly what I need is coming towards me
because I become a magnet.
I become an energy field
that is so magnetizing,
that is so excited, that's so inspired
that other people want to support
and work with that energy.
And so when we dwell in the
energy of joy and happiness,
we become a magnet for
that which we desire.
So my hope for you all
is to start to think
about the things that
you want to succeed in.
Whether it's succeeding
in romantic relationships
or succeeding in your career
or succeeding in your health goals
and make a commitment
today to bring more joy
to that area of your life.
Rather than seeing it as a struggle,
rather than pushing
forward with all this angst
and negativity and neediness and control,
just bring joy to it.
Your successes will come
when you commit to joy,
when you commit to happiness.
So find more joy in
that physical exercise.
I've been going to soul cycle.
I absolutely love it.
It's so joyful for me and
that's helping me raise my butt
'cause that was one of
my goals in success.
And then we have these moments
where we want to really
bring joy into our career.
Well if you're having a
hard time in the office,
just find ways to have more fun.
And as we start to elevate
that presence of joy,
we will begin to magnetize
the successes in our life.
And so take this very seriously.
Bring this practice into
your day to day experiences
and make joy and happiness
your number one priority
and recognize how your
successes will be brought to you
in a form far greater than
you could ever imagine
when your primary focus is happiness.
Once you make that willingness to change,
the book falls off the shelf
or the teacher shows up in a form
that you could have never imagined
or you hear something on the
radio or you meet a cab driver
or some enlightened conversation
comes into your realm
that all the sudden is
that shift that you needed
to make that change and
create that catalyst
that becomes your greatest accomplishment,
your greatest shift.
And so that's all we need at first
is that slight willingness,
that willingness that I had,
that desire to change,
that moment to shift,
was all I needed to become
the woman I am today.
To live that life beyond
my wildest dreams.
And so when I became ready,
I opened up and I said,
"Okay, I'm ready for change."
But what's beautiful
and what is the main
purpose of what I teach
is that once you make
that decision to change,
you do not have to do it by yourself.
You cannot be expected to make
these changes on your own.
All you need is that slight willingness.
If you're resenting somebody else,
you're really just unconsciously
resenting yourself.
So witnessing very quickly
who do I need to forgive?
Is it me, is it somebody else?
And very quickly turning it back onto you
and choosing the pathway of forgiveness.
Forgiving yourself for
having a judgmental thought.
Forgiving yourself for being an attack.
Forgiving yourself for having
a feeling that is unkind.
Forgiving yourself for being
judgmental towards yourself
or attacking towards yourself.
Whatever's up for the moment,
just practice the F word.
And if you can't get to the
feeling of forgiving yourself,
say that you are willing
to forgive yourself.
Just saying in that moment,
"I am willing to forgive myself for X Y Z.
"I am willing to forgive myself
for being in this bad mood.
"I'm willing to forgive
myself for what I just said.
"I'm willing to forgive myself
for what I'm holding on to."
And just opening yourself
up to the practice
of self forgiveness will change
your mood and your energy
in a minute or less.
I swear by this.
This is probably the key to
my freedom, my happiness,
my successes is my
willingness to forgive myself.
So take that in and
really own that for you
and practice the F word all the time.
So the next time you notice
yourself in a bad mood,
it might just be right
in this moment right now,
just say, "I'm willing to forgive myself."
And see what unfolds.
See how your energy changes.
See how your feelings begin to shift
and see that bad mood
just dissipate instantly.
There are no idle thoughts.
So if you want to live a mindful life,
you have to recognize the
magnitude of your thinking.
If you're sitting here and
you're judging your loved ones
or you're judging a friend,
you're weakening your own energy
and you're weakening theirs.
Every being around you in some way
is picking up the
frequency of your thoughts.
Some people are looking at me perplexed.
Like what the hell is she talking about?
Right now I can hear your thoughts.
(laughter)
I can, I know exactly
what you're thinking.
(laughter)
It's not that I can hear
it, it's that I can feel it.
Think about it.
You could be in those relationships
where your boss and you
do everything perfectly,
but in your head you're like I hate you,
I hate you, I hate you, I hate you.
And they don't want to promote you.
They don't want to support you.
There's constant tension
within the relationship.
You could say all the right things,
but if you don't think it,
if you don't transform and
clean up your thinking,
then you're literally
polluting the planet.
So first and foremost,
we got to think about what we're thinking.
And so how do we change those thoughts?
Because you might be thinking
okay, that sounds great,
but I'm down negative Nancy lane
and I don't know how to change direction.
How do I make a u-turn?
All right, so some simple tools.
First and foremost, witness it.
Yesterday I was saying this.
Look at your crazy and
call it by its name.
It's fear.
When you see those crazy
thoughts show up in your life,
when you hear those thoughts
of I'm not good enough,
I'm better than, that person's terrible,
I have two choices.
I can continue down the road
and I can continue down that dark path,
or I can actually pivot.
I can redirect, I can choose again.
So let's just play it out.
You're walking around Wanderlust
and somebody cuts you in
line to the pizza truck.
And you know I'd be pissed.
Somebody cut me in line
to that pizza truck.
And you want to go like why
they cut me in line and.
In that space, notice your angst.
Witness your story.
And instead of thinking
I'm going to fight back,
think that is a call for love.
Anyone who has the audacity
to cut me in the pizza line.
But seriously, anyone that's rude,
'cause I cut in the pizza line sometimes.
I'm a cutter.
(laughter)
I like to cut lines.
But really, what is it?
It's my own insecurity being
like I got to show people
that I can get ahead of the line.
Whatever it is, right?
Seeing it and being like
that is their call for love.
That's their unconsciousness.
That's their lack of mindfulness.
Really, really feel
what it would feel like
to be in the action of what it
is that you are dreaming of.
And what does that feel like
to be on the career path
that is your dream
or what does it feel like to
be doing the work in the world
that you've been so longing to bring forth
or what does it feel like to be spreading
an empowering message in a
unique and innovative way?
And in the process of
gathering those feelings,
we do it through meditation.
Sit in your meditation for
two to three minutes a day
and just allow yourself
to cultivate the feeling
of what it is that you desire.
I have had many experiences
throughout my life
where I've just allowed
myself to be in the feeling
of service or in the
feeling of excitement,
of seeing myself on a stage
and the feeling of seeing
myself sitting next to Oprah
doing an interview.
And all of those emotional feelings
that came forth in my meditations
became the manifestations of my life.
So take very seriously the
thoughts and the feelings.
When we start to shift our perceptions,
when we start to see things
with a better perspective,
when we start to see our experiences
as obstacles turning into opportunities
or a resentment as a divine
assignment to forgive more
or a moment of lack as an opportunity
to focus on what we're grateful for
rather than focus on what we don't have.
When we start to make these
shifts within our life,
what begins to happen is that
we begin to have more faith
in that way of being.
And so the neat thing that occurs,
and this has been my
experience the past six years
of practicing the life of a spirit junkie,
is that now, my choices,
my moment to moment choices
are choosing more of a
positive perspective.
When there's traffic, my
first thought is okay,
I welcome the traffic to go.
I start to think about the way.
Or if I'm supposed to be late?
Maybe I'm meant to be there late.
Maybe there's something greater coming.
Or if something doesn't
happen the exact way
that I believe it should happen,
I know and my first thought is
there's something way greater coming.
So this is just the types
of miracles that occur
and the ways that your
mind begins to shift
when you start to
practice these principles
in every corner of your life.
I think it's really valuable for us
to recognize that we,
when we're on a spiritual
path, that's our path,
but it's not for everybody.
And not everyone wants to
know every detail of our path.
We have to trust that
our shift in perception,
our energetic changes are
the raising of our own energy
will help raise the energy
of other people around us.
And hopefully we'll start
to see how we are no longer
an energetic match for the
people that don't think
and feel the way that we feel.
And so slowly we'll
begin to see those folks
begin to melt away.
We'll see them disappear.
We'll see them fall off in our life
and we'll see some of our
relationships begin to change.
And sometimes that's a little
bit alarming for people,
but it's actually a good sign.
It's a sign that you are not
stuck in that pattern anymore.
It's a sign that your desire
to change has been lifted
and that you now are
vibrating in a new frequency
and those relationships will melt away.
If those relationships are
still coming up for you
while you're in this
path of transformation,
what I often say is rather
than pointing the finger
at those people saying,
"Oh, you're ruining my life.
"You're making things difficult."
My hope and my intention for you
would be that you begin to
look at those folks and say,
"What is it about me
that is still triggered
"by their behavior?
"What is it in me that may be attracting
"this type of person into my life?
"What is it within me
"that is still calling in
this kind of experience?"
And so get honest with yourself.
What is it within me
that's calling this in?
How am I participating in this
and how is this experience
coming from a dark corner
within my psyche?
And recognizing that the outside world
is always reflecting
our internal condition.
And recognizing the mirror
that people are always
mirroring back to us
what we are feeling.
So if she has people
coming up into her life,
negative friends, people that are jealous,
she says, "Negative people
randomly popping back in."
And she wants to keep them at a distance.
Well the real work is to just
open and rev up your practice.
Pray for them, extend light to them,
and sometimes politely excuse
yourself from the experience.
Sometimes we have to remove ourselves
from those experiences.
And then most importantly, ask
yourself what is it within me
that may be attracting
some of this behavior?
Get honest with yourself.
Okay.
No matter what's up,
choose to show up with love.
Choose to show up with grace.
Now if something really tough is up,
maybe just choose to show
up with self compassion.
If you're going through something,
I'm not going to sit here and recommend
that if you're going
through a traumatic period
in your life, I'm not going to recommend
that you wake up and you're like
it's rainbows and butterflies
and Gabby Bernstein Spirit Junkie App.
No.
That's not what I'm going to recommend.
What I'm going to recommend
is you wake up and you say,
"I'm going to choose to
see myself with love today.
"I'm going to choose to be compassionate
"and kind to myself today.
"I'm going to choose to go slow today."
But that's still a very,
very mindful morning, okay?
And the morning is probably
the most crucial time
to be conscious of your mindfulness
and show up with grace and
show up with love and bring it.
Bring it, bring it,
bring it in the morning.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Kim asked me to.
Also, if you want to nominate someone
for the next top 10 video,
please check the description
for a link to a video
where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned,
that blew your mind, that you're
going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Steph Reveron.
Steph, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and posting another great
picture to Instagram.
I really appreciate the support
and I'm glad you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- It's very easy to show up
at work every day and say,
"I hate this.
"I can't stand my boss.
"I hate sitting next to this person.
"My cubicle sucks."
There's a million ways we can
get completely whacked out
with the stories of why
we don't like our job.
So just have fun and
lean towards the things
that elevate you.
And the more you focus on the
things that are fun for you
and the more you focus on
the good that is around you,
the more fun you become.
The more cool you become.
When you're in that place of you're cool,
people want to do more with you.
You'll get those assignments
that are going to be far more exciting.
The people that may be difficult
in your career relationships
will start to actually change.
They'll see you differently.
They'll act differently around you.
When you're having a good time,
the people around you have a good time.
And that will help you
get ahead very quickly,
smoothly, and with joy.
The next phase here is
also to become grateful
for what it is that you do have.
So if you're starting to try
to create change in your life,
you want to make sure that
you're really focusing
on what it is that you
do have in your life
so that you feel an energy of gratitude.
And an energy of gratitude
can really open you up
to this incredible capacity
to feel more energized,
to feel more happy.
In any given moment
where you feel like oh,
I don't have what I need
or I'm not supported
or things aren't working out,
the simple step here is to just say,
"I am grateful for what I do have."
And when we look and we say
I am grateful for what I do have,
we create more of what we want.
And the energy of
gratitude opens our heart
and it expands our energy
and it makes us a much more
wonderful, loving person
to be around.
And with that loving energy,
we begin to attract more into our life.
And so we want to really make sure
that that energy of gratitude
is a very pinnacle part
of this miracle worker process,
which is that we stay committed and open
to what it is that we are here to receive.
And we stay committed and grateful
for what it is that we have.
And so you can begin today
just by making a gratitude list
and focus on it.
And there are so many moments
when I think oh my God,
I can't believe I have to do this
or I can't believe I have to get to that.
And then I just think
about what I'm grateful for
and it just spins me immediately
out of the crazy chaos
and back into a centered place of love.
And so I think that this
is a really valuable tool
for you to begin to use regularly
and it's an active tool
throughout the book May Cause Miracles.
When you fully accept that
you are here to be great,
when you fully accept that
you are here to be happy,
you are here to receive,
when you fully accept that you can have
the peace and the serenity and the joy
and the wisdom and the purpose
and the intention that you
intend to bring to the world
and that it is all available to you,
that's when life gets very groovy.
And so my hope and my intention for today
is to wake you up to that presence
and more importantly,
give you a really great New
York City kick in the ass
that says not only I'm awake to it,
not only do I believe in it,
but I am committed to it.
I am unapologetic about
my capacity to be great.
my capacity to heal.
I am unapologetic about my capacity
to see beyond my physical sight.
I am unapologetic about
my capacity to shine
as bright as I can shine
because I trust and I know
that when I shine bright,
I give others permission to do the same
and in my glow, they wake up too.
And that is why we're here.
(applause)